précédée du garde du corps et de
l'attaché de presse les stars protégés
se font des confidences
malgré le rythme infernal il enchaîne
les entretiens plutôt de bonne humeur
voici donc mart catherine et daniel les
trois héros de ma saison préférée
l'histoire de famille doux lourd
heureuse malgré des apparences
trompeuses
c'est bon on manger quand on mange pas
on parle de ce qu'on a mangé de ce qu'on
va manger parce qu'enfin il cessa la
famille c du chan
c'est toi qui dis ça disons que j'ai une
petite préférence pour monfils oh mon
fiston
nous sommes davantage car invitait
quazar en voulez vous qu'on s'en sorte
mais mikko mais j'aime une fille qui
devenus adultes a bien du mal à se
libérer de son frère
j'ai construit ma vie sans lui j'ai très
vite reproduit comme ça des schémas de
famille
on lui échappe et d'internet à fond est
à cela qu répond le frère le frère dit
que la soeur vide
erreur et qu'elle qu'elle ne l'aviez
absolument pas dans les rêves que nous
avions projeté lorsque nous étions
enfants s'épuise à ce qu'on n'ose pas
choquant en surface pour permis ces
prédateurs sexuels de t systems en
allait bien merde voilà c'est comme ça
c'est trop tard gd vous n'êtes vous pas
sentir un tel parce que c'est des fous
on a frôlé des choses qui sont si
dérangeante mais en même temps qu'il
vous apporte beaucoup qui sont des
choses très très intime et personnelle
quand gré
seulement 2
elle n'en a l'air
pour toi pourquoi ça c'est super mal qui
sont très très complices vous et très
complices aussi ce trio d'acteurs devenu
manifestement une sorte de famille qui
ce soir montera les marches du palais
pour affronter le festival mais j'ai
fait des choses dans ma vision
difficile de grimper démarche j'aime
beaucoup
non moi je pense que ça les descendants
se faire ça sera plus émouvant c'est
après après le sommet d accorder dans
quel état mais c'est ça ce qui est
certain c'est que les spectateurs comme
ces acteurs seront profondément
bouleversé par ces sentiments cachés
intime sincère et violent cambrai
téchiné a su si bien révélé et qui nous
concerne tous